The typical program looks like this.
First, the CPU allocates storage on the GPU.
Then, the CPU copies some input data from the CPU to the GPU.
Next, the CPU calls some kernels watching these kernels on the GPU that process this data.
And finally, the CPU copies the results back to the CPU from the GPU.
Now, two of these steps require moving data back and forth between the CPU and the GPU.
Is this expensive?
Well, in general, you'd like to minimize data transfer between the CPU and the GPU as much as you can.
If you're going to move a lot of data and do only a little bit of computation on that data,
Cuda or GPU computing probably isn't a great fit for your problem.
Generally, we've found that the most successful GPU computing applications do a lot of computation
and have a high ratio of computation to communication.
They send their data to the GPU.
They do a lot of work, and only then, they bring it back.